catholique hindous musulmans sont
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'indiens
a pleuré le jour dit mère teresa dans
l'église saint-thomas de calcutta
ils viennent malgré les pluies de la
mousson apporter quelques fleurs à celle
qui leur a témoigné en compassion ici
même
la jeune soeur agnès son véritable
prénom comment sa mission en inde
c'était en 1929 elle deviendra plus tard
mère teresa en souvenir de
sainte-thérèse de lisieux et fondera
l'ordre des missionnaires de la charité
4000 membres aujourd'hui et près de 600
et stu sion chacun ici partagent la même
émotion
mais c'est la mer elle nous aidera a
mené l'épreuve de bout du délai aucun
mail pour la dire chargé des mre d'un an
après celle de windows
moi je suis un chef mais il n'a pas mis
de frontières entre les religions
chaises et les gars c'est vrai il y en a
fait roi une date était sa plus grande
richesse est la protéine aux chrétiens
la prochaine approach quelle que soit sa
religion chacun de tennis c'est vrai il
ya là plus important pour nice grasse
elle était négative notre action la
presse de calcutta associe aujourd'hui
la mort de mère teresa et celle de lady
diana
les deux maires unissent le monde dans
le chagrin ito en titre les funérailles
auront lieu samedi elles ont été retardé
pour permettre à de nombreuses
personnalités internationales y assister